is it possible for someone who has a
normal income to do this diet meat is
expensive is it not so it's totally
possible to do this on a very low budget
it can be way cheaper than eating the
standard American diet what you want to
do is you want to go to a butcher or go
to your meat department and just buy the
cheap cuts it doesn't matter what they
are buy the cheap Cuts you could survive
off of tongue if you needed to that's
dirt cheap and if you go to my handy
website liondiet.com there is a recipe
for crunchy things and you can literally
make the most garbage cuts into
delicious crispy things by adding fat so
you can buy fat from a butcher fat is
really cheap they commonly cut fat off
of cuts and throw it away so make
friends with a butcher buy fat buy the
cheap Cuts you can do a heart too you
can do organs get the cheap Cuts add fat
get a pressure cooker and an air fryer
and you're set they will save you so
much time and they'll make your food so
good it's really worth investing into
them